[Música]
503 gostaria de pedir rigor das senhas
número convosco
gosto de cuidar cento gosto de chegar ao
escritório e ainda na calma da manhã
houve alguns problemas que ficaram
pendurados do dia anterior mas acordo
principalmente cedo para evitar a hora
do planeta e o trânsito infernal
levanta a mão quem aqui mora de casa ao
trabalho de porta a porta em média 15
minutos
levanta a mão ok 30 minutos uma hora de
casa ao trabalho
quantos de nós não pode o pé no
acelerador porque estávamos atrasados
por um procon compromisso ou provocar o
trabalho infringindo até algumas regras
de trânsito
quantos de nós não tendo já parado no
engarrafamento infinito de zero que
alguma tecnologia assinada com o
teletransporte se tivesse já sido
inventada
alguns dados primeiro o porto em 2018
foi considerada a pior cidade portuguesa
para andar de carro
mesmo à frente lisboa que é uma cidade
com mais população
para quem conhece o porto locais como
circunvalação vice e um túnel de águas
santas nove franquias somos conhecidos
por maus motivos em média possamos 27
horas anuais no trânsito
mas nem tudo é mão em 2016 portugal foi
considerado o país da união europeia com
mais baixa média de emissões de dióxido
carbônico na atmosfera para carros novos
de nossa gente
contudo em 2018
portugal viu nas suas estradas mais de
132 mil acidentes rodoviários mais 2 mil
distinta do que em 2017
destes acidentes resultaram 2063 fritz
kraft alguns deus com escolas para toda
a vida
em 2018 ocorreram destes acidentes 503
norte apresentando a sua vida com o
segundo ano consecutivo esta semana
quando deslocava para o trabalho
ouvi as estatísticas do primeiro
trimestre de 2009 já morreram 116
pessoas este ano em todo mundo há
milhares de engenheiros engenheiros que
estão a trabalhar para tentar solucionar
esse problema
desenvolvendo implementar os sistemas de
assistência ao condutor e condução
autônoma
o carro será capaz de se localizar com
grande precisão no planeta isso lidar
com objetos e uma envolvente como
cruzamentos sinais de trânsito peões que
atravessam a estrada pequenos objetos ou
animais
mas tal como todos os sistemas complexos
que são desenvolvidos hoje em dia esse é
um processo que foi de paz ou quase
para isso foram definidos diferentes
níveis de condução autônoma
no primeiro caso o nível zero não há
qualquer nível de automação aqui vemos
os carros do passado
já no nível 1 de anos uma funcionária
gradativa por exemplo a condição da
travagem automática em que o carro
consegue automaticamente detetar que o
carro da frente está a aproximar
demasiado e travar o nível 2 que é o que
já existe nas nossas estradas
vemos duas funcionalidades ativas
simultaneamente como por exemplo se
entrar na faixa de rodagem e cruz
controlo adaptativo aqui o condutor será
capaz em alguns áreas de tirar as mãos
do volante e fazer algumas atividades
estarão sempre sentado no lugar do
condutor a partir do nível 3 com nível 4
nível 5
começam então os níveis mais
interessantes
funcionalidades mais atrativas no nível
além de retirarmos as mãos do volante o
condutor vai ser capaz de tirar os olhos
da estrada vai ser capaz de enviar
mensagens não quer dizer que hoje em dia
não façamos mans fra será mais fácil ler
um livro e até ver um filme ter ainda
que está sentado no lugar do condutor
para garantir que pode retomar o
controle do carro em questões de
segurança que ela seja necessário
já no nível 4 e cimento nível 3 mas aqui
o passageiro o condutor será visto mais
como um sujeito e durará até ir para um
lugar atrás e do mesmo nível físico o
sonho visão poderão até não haver nós
nem volante
qualquer intervenção humana condição não
será necessária
o futuro passará por entrar conca quer
pode não ser nós a ir ao local de
destino que eu já previamente inserir
fazer qualquer outra coisa que não seja
a conduzir chegar sair do carro vai
estacionar sozinho ou então até ser
utilizado por outras pessoas
a linha do equador
mede aproximadamente 40 mil quilômetros
em estudo estatístico nos estados unidos
foram apresentadas os valores para as
quais foram apresentados os valores de
quilômetros percorridos propostas
acontece um acidente assim para carros
em piloto automático e que violentou
olival onde automação foi possível
observar um acidente por causa 702 mil
quilômetros já uma marca conhecida
condição altona apresentou as suas
estatísticas por último trimestre de
2008 apresentando uma se antes por cada
quase 5 milhões de quilômetros
percorridos
este sistema equivalente ao nível 2
permite efectivamente que a pessoa possa
descontrair e aproveitar a viagem
e que vemos um aspecto interessante
comparativo um carro que nós temos hoje
em dia nem vallon um carro que já está
no percurso do futuro e ainda bem longe
daquilo que nós visionamos é quase sete
vezes mais seguro e com o carro lá na
indústria automóvel a segurança das
pessoas ea segurança na prevenção da
manipulação dos dados são fundamentais
por isso muito investimento é feito para
que o sistema seja esteja próximo do da
falha zero porque todos os fornecedores
e marcas automóveis sabem o quanto é
crucial para a grande aceitação desta
tecnologia da condição altona com todas
as potencialidades para trazer
na imagem podemos ver algumas das marcas
que têm já neste momento carros teste
com sistemas equivalentes a nível 3 na
califórnia o local que tenha um regime
especial para testes de carros autônomos
na linha da frente temos ao irmão
o projeto anteriormente conhecido como
carro autônomo da google
aqui foi já possível mostrar que o car
conseguiu conduzir sem qualquer
intervenção do condutor por mais de 18
mil quilômetros
essas marcas possuem várias estratégias
para verificar os seus sistemas várias
estratégias de testes
umas delas passam por testes em
laboratório por estações de teste com a
guarda real nos permitem por exemplo
verificar a sessão ea transmissão dos
dados feita ao meio escondido foi tal
pronor senhor teste também em ambientes
virtuais e de simulação que nos permitem
por exemplo verificar a validade dos
dados em condições adversas como túneis
como os mais urbanos ou então quem sabe
até no futuro mais próximo do nosso em
qualquer uma das ruas ondas portuguesas
conhecemos bem a realidade da tuna da
boa vista
por fim os testes em ambiente real são
fundamentais
é que os testes são feitos nos
componentes individuais em subsistema em
um sistema completo vem com os autônomos
eletrificação e conectividade são ponto
chave para chamada visão 00 30
sicilianos de emissões
o primeiro traz o primeiro zero está
intimamente ligado com os outros dois
por com certeza os nossos níveis de
stress vão aumentar exponencialmente
estiveram envolvidos nos acidentes
nós tivemos no maiô kuyt e cão veículos
por convênios partilhados carregam
automaticamente estância não sozinhos
como vemos os nossos grandes centros
urbanos com certeza menos brilhante mais
aberto e livre de stress
ouvimos dizer que tempo é dinheiro
eu penso que tempo é investimento e de
acordo com os nossos objetivos este
investimento pode ser feito diversas
formas
devemos apostar no nosso regulamento
pessoal meditação ou então descansar
podemos nos focar na família ouvir o que
efetivamente está a ser dito ajudar as
nossas crianças nos trabalhos de casa
ouvir aquelas histórias da escola que
temos realmente que eu vi
nós podemos também focar no
entretenimento porque há simplesmente 9
às boas séries e filmes problema e não
nos podemos esquecer de todos os
acidentes e mortes podem ser evitados
essa tecnologia vai nos permitir muito
mais a uma série de números que não está
aqui hoje podem ser evitados por essa
tecnologia por erro humano distração mas
decisões
a mudança está a acontecer e mais
próximo do podem esperar vamos ter
carros sem condutor nas nossas estradas
e estes desenvolvimentos vamos ajudar a
confiar nessa tecnologia
se há desafios certamente teremos que
pensar
nos empregos que potencialmente poderão
ser pedidos à indústria dos transportes
e nos serviços automóveis
sabemos que temos que ter cuidado extra
com a privacidade e partilha dos dados
que vão acontecer entre carros e até
carros e infraestrutura
e claro os nossos algoritmos de
inclusivas artificial têm que ser
substituídos o suficiente para lidar com
os sistemas caóticos com cidades como a
índia em que uma comunicação principal
dos condutores é a buzina já ninguém
deveria morrer com o nível da série ao
nível da tecnologia que nós temos neste
momento
e pra isso estes milhares de engenheiros
engenheiros estão a trabalhar todos os
dias para que esses sistemas de condução
autônoma funciona em qualquer comissão
teológica condição das trava devia e
noite diante de temas que dão a
informação correta na altura certa
só assim poderemos confiar em uma
tecnologia que vai definitivamente mudar
as nossas vidas
imaginem um mundo sem poluição
atmosférica ou senhora imagina em
portugal o porto com o trânsito fluindo
sem preocupações
imaginem não termos ninguém não familiar
um amigo o cognitivo da criança este
número
[Aplausos]